Accelerated flight. In accelerated flight it's important that you try to keep the hands fully stretched up.
You can also, if you want, hold yourself a bit on the rear risers, because in accelerated flight we can only steer with weight shift.
And if that's not enough, then we add a very light pull on the rearmost riser.
So that means, set up the accelerator — or how do you accelerate: if, like me, he gets into the first stirrup well,
he goes with the heel into this first stirrup, pushes it a bit far enough so that with the second foot he could step back onto the next step,
and then bring the second foot also onto this step.
You see, I have such a flexible one — most of you have that — if you have a bar, it goes a bit more easily.
Yes, then we look for symmetry with the feet a bit and then we push the accelerator very slowly fully up.
And ideally then the accelerator is, like here on the right, pulley over pulley, or at least pulley on pulley.
Here on the left you see, we still have a bit of distance between the individual pulleys.
It's not much now, that just comes from the fact that we have a certain asymmetry in there.
If I take the legs further out, then you see, we have there,
symmetry and the pulleys engage guaranteed.
That would be fully accelerated and now it's important, steering only with weight shift.
Yes, if that's not enough, then we may lightly pull on the rear riser.
So one centimetre, at most two, so we have little working area.
Good, exit the accelerator, simply sit neutral or if we're making a turn to the other side,
we finish that first and then sit neutral.
And slowly come back off the accelerator.
The last few centimetres you can then for all I care let snap out.
What's important is, during accelerated flight you must not steer with the brake.
The explanation comes later in the brake grip section.